[Music]
[Applause]
imagine being dumped in a field of wheat
and being told somewhere in here is a
needle try and find it yeah well that's
what film editors face every day sifting
sorting saving actors asses and
assembling the endless hours of footage
until that needle is found a great
editor can help a director see a scene
or even a whole film in our whole new
light even remind the director why he
made the film in the first place
so let's give them an award already
exactly here are the nominees for
achievement in film editing American
sniper
Joel cogs and Gary D Roach boyhood
Sandra Adair the grand Budapest hotel
barney pilling the imitation game
william Goldenberg whiplash Tom Cross
and the Oscar goes to Tom cross whiplash
[Applause]
nomination for
cross
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow I want to thank the Academy for
honoring whiplash with this award I
couldn't have done this without the
contributions of the entire cast and
crew of whiplash Blum house bold films
right away films our amazing team at
Sony Pictures Classics Michael Barker
and Tom Barnard and our team at WME also
my assistant editors John tonne Eugene
Locke I couldn't have done it without
you guys
miles teller and JK Simmons I need to
thank you for delivering gold to the
cutting room every day and most of all I
need to thank the person who never once
threw a chair at my head but always push
to make it better the writer and
director Damien Chazelle Damien I
I want to thank you from the bottom of
my heart for sharing this journey with
me I I will forever be indebted to you
your art changed my life and to La
Crosse and Jim cross my mother and
father and my beautiful wife Holly and
my children Nova and Perry you made my
life thank you so much
[Music]